حسنًا، انضم إلي الآن حسن الحسن
زميل أبحاث في سياسة الشرق الأوسط
في المعهد الدولي للدراسات
الاستراتيجية وهو معنا من
المنامة في البحرين، شكرًا جزيلاً
لانضمامكم إلينا،
شكرًا لاستضافتي في
أعقاب وحشية حماس وقمعها.
الهجمات المروعة يوم السبت الماضي هدف إسرائيل هو
القضاء على الجماعة المسلحة
وتدمير بنيتها التحتية الإرهابية
بهذه الضربات الجوية المستمرة واسعة النطاق
ومن ثم التوغل البري المحتمل
ولكن ما هي المخاطر
والتكاليف التي ينطوي عليها ذلك بالنسبة للمدنيين الأبرياء
وبالطبع أه للرهائن المحتجزين
تحت الأرض نظرا لأن حماس تعرف أن
نظام الأنفاق أفضل بكثير من أي من
قوات جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي نعم في الحقيقة من الصعب جدا
أن نتصور كيف يمكن لإسرائيل أن تحقق
هدفها المتمثل في الإبادة الكاملة لحماس
أه دون قتل عدة آلاف أخرى
من الفلسطينيين أه وهذا جزئيا
بسبب  كون قطاع غزة
أه أه محصور منذ
حوالي 16 سنة أه وهكذا أه
أصبح من أكثر الأماكن اكتظاظا بالسكان
في العالم الأحياء
والمباني مكتظة ببعضها البعض أه
البنية التحتية الصحية أصلا
غير كافية  لذا فإن الناس في غزة لديهم متوسط
عمر متوقع أقل بنحو 10
سنوات من أه معظم الناس في إسرائيل
أم ولذلك لدينا حوالي نصف مليون
فلسطيني يلجأون إلى المدارس التي
تديرها أه الأمم المتحدة ولكن حتى هذه
غير كافية أه والأمم المتحدة  حذرت من أه أنهم معرضون لخطر
نفاد
المياه أه المستشفيات في غزة أيضا معرضة
بشدة لخطر
الاجتياح أه وبالتالي أه الأمور
تفاقمت بسبب أه حقيقة أن إسرائيل
فرضت حصارا أيضا بقطع
الكهرباء  الماء والوقود والغذاء أه
وهذا يعني أن
الوضع الإنساني في غزة بالفعل
محفوف بالمخاطر للغاية أه ومطالبة 1.1 مليون
شخص بالانتقال جنوبًا في مكان يبلغ
حجمه تقريبًا حجم سياتل أو ديترويت أه
أه ليس ممكنًا تمامًا أه
والحقيقة  هو أن استراتيجية إسرائيل ليست
فقط أخلاقية وقانونية أه موضع شك
ولكن أعتقد أنها
استراتيجية سيئة في الأساس أه بمعنى أن
إيقاع
أه أعداد كبيرة من الضحايا المدنيين
من أجل هزيمة حماس هو في نهاية المطاف
هزيمة ذاتية لأنه بقتل
المدنيين الفلسطينيين على نطاق واسع  تقوم إسرائيل
ببساطة بتزويد حماس
بجيلها القادم من المقاتلين عن طريق دفع الناس
إلى أه حافة اليأس أه إنها
في الأساس تغذي هذه الرواية وذكرى القمع
المتوارثة بين الأجيال أه،
لذا أعتقد أن هذا
حق ستراتي مهزوم ذاتيًا
وإحساسك هو أنه ليس  إن الهدف الذي
يمكن تحقيقه بأي حال من الأحوال، وهو أنه لا يمكن
القضاء على حماس، هو أن ما تقوله
جيدًا أنه يمكن تحقيقه ولكن ليس
بالوسائل العسكرية، فإن أفضل طريقة للقضاء علينا
هي إبعادنا بالطبع عن حرمانها من
قضيتها، وذلك عن طريق  السعي
بجدية نحو طريق نحو السلام وإنهاء
الاحتلال غير القانوني وتزويد
الفلسطينيين بالأمل.
لم تنجح فكرة استعادة الردع بالنسبة
لإسرائيل، فالصراع المستمر هو
أكبر مثال على ذلك ومحاولة
العودة إليه هي في الأساس
عودة إلى نفس العيوب.
النموذج الأمني ​​المفاهيمي أه الذي فشل حتى الآن
أه في حماية الإسرائيليين أفضل طريقة
لهزيمة حماس واستعادة الردع هي
من خلال الأمل وليس من خلال
الخوف ولكن يعني بصراحة كيف يمكن
ذلك لأنه من الواضح أنني
أقصد أن إسرائيل تستجيب لما  كان
هجومًا قاتلًا على أراضيها أدى إلى مقتل
أطفال ونساء وأطفال أه لذا أعني أنك
تفهم ما يغذي هذا
ليس
بالضرورة أنك لا تستطيع قبول ما
يحدث في غزة أيضًا ولكن أعني أنه
يمكنك رؤية مدى فظاعة ذلك الهجوم
ولماذا  ستشعر الأمة بأنها
تريد الانتقام، كيف يتم ذلك هو
السؤال الذي نحاول معالجته،
لذا أخبرني ما هو الطريق للمضي قدمًا في
ذلك، لذا علينا أن نتذكر أن هذه
ليست الحرب الأولى بين إسرائيل وحماس
و  في كل مرة
ردت إسرائيل من خلال الاستخدام غير المتناسب
للقوة مما أدى إلى سقوط عدة
آلاف من الضحايا الفلسطينيين، وكيف أن
ذلك لم يكن جيدًا جدًا،
وبالتالي في الغياب التام
لمسار سياسي قابل للتطبيق، يجب أن يكون هذا تغييرًا
في توجه إسرائيل نحو
القضية الفلسطينية الإسرائيلية تجاه
القضية الفلسطينية أه وهذا يعني أنه
يجب أن يكون هناك حساب داخل
إسرائيل بأن
الاستخدام الساحق غير المتناسب للقوة قد
فشل في حماية إسرائيل حتى الآن أه
ودون مسار قابل للحياة لتسوية
سلمية تفاوضية يعني ذلك  أه أه
ليس على الفلسطينيين أن يعيشوا
تحت حصار شامل أه يمكنهم أه أن
يحصلوا على حقوقهم بموجب
القانون الدولي بدون ذلك
ببساطة لن يكون هناك أمل والأجيال القادمة
من الفلسطينيين
ستتذكر أه أه كيف ردت إسرائيل
عليهم  اه أعتقد ببساطة أنه سيتم دفعنا
إلى حافة التطرف مرة أخرى
وسنرى المزيد من دورات
العنف لذلك أعتقد أنه بدون
حل سياسي حقيقي بدون
مسار واضح سيكون من الصعب جدًا
رؤية كيف يمكننا كسر أه هذه الدورة بشكل دائم
من أه العنف نعم وللأسف
لا يوجد مسار سياسي واضح في الوقت الحالي يجب أن
يقال على الرغم من أن حماس على
ما يبدو أمضت عامين في التحضير
لهجمات الأسبوع الماضي على إسرائيل ما هو
هدفهم المحتمل وماذا كانوا
يتوقعون تحقيقه بالنظر إلى أن
القيادة كانت ستحقق  معروف أن إسرائيل
ستنتقم بقوة لم
تشهدها من قبل لتمسح فأرتها من على
الخريطة فلماذا فعلوا هذا ما كانت
نهاية
اللعبة لذلك أعتقد أه اللعبة النهائية الأولية
كانت تدمير رواية إسرائيل التي لا تقهر
أه فكرة أنه حتى  أه
أقوى قوة عسكرية في
المنطقة أه يمكن أن تهزم وتهزم
وتتأذى لذلك أعتقد أن هذا
كان أول نوع من الهدف النفسي لحماس
أه والذي كان في الواقع يضعف فكرة
أن إسرائيل لا تقهر وأعتقد أن
الهدف الآخر أه هو بالضبط  الفخ الذي
تسير فيه إسرائيل والذي هو
إثارة
رد فعل إسرائيلي مبالغ فيه ومن خلال إثارة
رد فعل إسرائيلي مبالغ فيه أه حماس أعتقد أنها تأمل في
تقويض أي دعم دولي أه
أن أه إسرائيل قد تكون قادرة على غارنر
أه أه أه لذلك أه أساسا
يمكننا دعم إسرائيل  ضمن
شركائها وحلفائها الغربيين، حسنًا، حسن
الحسن، شكرًا جزيلاً لانضمامك
إلينا ونقدر وجهة نظرك بشأن
هذه
القضية